Let’s talk about object features.
We’ve already talked about describing the
position of an object.
We’ve worked out how to describe the centroid
of an object, which is a useful way of describing
where something is within the image.
We’ve also talked about determining the
size of an object—its area—and we can
get that information from the zeroth moments.
We might be interested to describe the shape
of an object; does it look like a shark, or
a triangle, or a circle, or a square, and
we might be interested in describing the orientation
of the object.
It’s quite important.
Is the shark pointing upwards, or to the left
or to the right?
So let’s talk about how we can compute some
of these additional object features.
Position we’ve already described in terms
of the bounding box and the centroid, which
is derived from first moments.
The size of the object; we also call it its
area, and it can be described form the zeroth
moments.
What we haven’t described so far is shape
and orientation, so let’s talk about that.
The way we’re going to do this is to use
a technique called the equivalent ellipse.
So for each of these shapes what we’re going
to do is to consider an ellipse that is centred
at the object’s centroid, and that has got
the same moment of inertia about that centroid
as the original shape has.
So this means for these different kinds of
shapes we’re going to get different shaped
equivalent ellipses and they’re going to
tell us something about the shape and the
orientation of the object.
This is quite a classical technique, but it’s
actually quite useful.
Let’s put it into practice.
Here is our shark image.
Here’s the centroid.
We’re going to define a set of orthogonal
axes; an x-axis and a y-axis that pass through
the centroid of the shark, and they’re parallel
to the u and v coordinates.
Now once I’ve got this coordinate system,
it’s easy to compute the inertia matrix
for the blob around the y and x axes about
the centroid.
And we do that by computing what are called
the central moments of the blob: mu, underscore,
p,q.
And this is very similar to the moment expression
we had earlier, except inside the brackets
we now subtract the coordinates of the centroid.
So if we compute these moments: mu,2,0, mu,0,2
and mu,1,1 for the blob we end up with a matrix
that contain the inertia values.
We want to find an ellipse that has got the
same inertia as those we derived from the
blob.
Now if this is the inertia matrix we can compute
its eigenvalues, and from those eigenvalues
we can compute the major and minor axis of
the ellipse.
That’s basically half the long axis of the
ellipse, and half the short axis of the ellipse.
These radii a and b are derived from the eigenvalues
of the matrix J. Lambda 1 is the largest eigenvalue,
and lambda 2 is the smaller eigenvalue.
We’re also interested in the orientation
of the ellipse; what’s the value of θ.
And we obtain θ from the elements of the
eigenvector that corresponds to the largest
eigenvalue.
So we take the ratio of the two elements in
the eigenvector, the arc tangent, and that
gives us θ.
That tells us the orientation of the ellipse,
and the orientation of the ellipse tells us
something about the orientation of the object
itself.
Another parameter that’s useful that we
can derive from the equivalent ellipse is
called the aspect ratio, that’s b/a.
B is the short length, a is the long length,
b/a is always less than 1.
And it says something about the compactness
of the shape.
So this shark, for instance, has got a ratio
of b over a that’s roughly 1, where this
shark has got a value b/a that’s much smaller
than 1.
So b/a says something about the compactness
of the shape.
Let’s load yet another variant of our shark
image, and we will display this.
And here we see two sharks, one pitched downwards,
and one pitched a little bit upwards.
We will compute the parameters of these blobs
using a familiar command to us, and we see
we’ve found three blobs: two shark blobs
and one background blob.
Let’s simplify things and get rid of the
background blob, since we’re really only
interested in the shark objects.
We use the iblobs function again; parse in
the image.
And we ask for just those blobs comprising
pixels that belong to class 1; that is, that
the colour 1 they are the white pixels within
the scene.
And now we have an array of blob objects but
only those objects that are white within the
scene: the two sharks.
Where each blob is displayed we see a number
of parameters or attributes of those blobs,
and some of those are quite familiar to use
now.
For instance, the area and the centroid.
The parameter θ is the orientation of the
blob.
Orientation is given in unit of radians, and
it is in respect to a coordinate frame attached
to the shark that’s parallel to the u and
v axes.
An orientation is positive in the clockwise
direction.
We can see that one shark has got a θ value
of 29 and the other shark has a θ value of
-2.58, so this suggests that they have different
orientations.
Another parameter here is the ratio b/a, and
we refer to that as the aspect ratio.
And what’s interesting here is that the
two sharks have got the same aspect ratio,
around about 0.585, or 0.586 and this is important
and interesting because the aspect ratio is
the same even though the sharks have got different
positions and different orientations, so we
refer to this as a shape in variant.
It’s a characteristic of the shark and it’s
independent of its position or its orientation.
Now we’ve talked a bit before about the
equivalent ellipse, and it’s pretty easy
to plot.
We apply the plot ellipse method to the vector
of shark blobs, and what this will do is plot
an equivalent ellipse for every element of
that vector, all of the objects in the vector
b, and here we see the two equivalent ellipses
plotted.
We can plot the centroids almost as easily
using the plot method, applied to every object
in the vector b.
So to summarise the object features that we
can derive for a blob.
We can describe its position in terms of bounding
box or centroid.
We can determine its size, its area.
We can look at its shape and that comes from
the aspect ratio of the equivalent ellipse,
and we can determine the orientation in the
object from the orientation of the equivalent
ellipse.